wollen von ihnen wissen was sie sich
vorgenommen haben zum jahresbeginn für
2022 weniger trinken mehr essen weniger
oder mehr küssen oder was weiß ich auch
immer es gibt tatsächlich viele viele
vorsätze auch viele skurrile schauen sie
mal
neues jahr und immer die selben vorsätze
abnehmen mehr sport machen
langweilig hierbei bild schlagen ihnen
die etwas andere neujahrsvorsätze vor
bevor sie sich neue vorsätze machen
erreichen sie doch mal die ziele die sie
sich 2021 vorgenommen haben oder 2020
oder 2019 oder wie wäre es damit einfach
eine unangenehme angewohnheit ablegen zb
weniger in der nase popeln eine
tätigkeit der umfrage zufolge jeder
zweite deutsche nachgeht und gehören sie
auch zu den personen die nie auf
nachrichten und mails antworten einfach
mal rechtzeitig schreiben und andere
nicht warten lassen und falls das nicht
klappt heißt das zauberwort digital die
talks handy oder laptop weg legen und
mehr in der realen welt verbringen dann
kann man sich endlich mehr zeit für
freunde und familie nehmen denn was gibt
es schöneres als sich mit seinen
liebsten bei einem brettspiel abend so
richtig zu zoffen
wenn sie sich dann zerstritten haben
haben sie endlich mehr zeit für sport
und an die sportmuffel keine sorge sport
schauen reicht auch mit diesen vorsitzen
wird 2022 ganz sicher hier ja
also endlich mal mehr streiten im neuen
jahr das ist doch mal was
das hat also unsere nicht ganz ernst
gemeinten vorsätze für das neue jahr die
sie zumindest beherzigen können wenn sie
wollen aber wenn sie enden wirklich
großen vorsatz haben den sie endlich mal
umsetzen wollen den inneren schweinehund
besiegen wollen dann schaffen sie das
dann schaffen wir das mit unserer hilfe
ja wir haben nämlich einen mann hier im
studio der heißt sparfuchs frank ochse
ist zu uns gekommen und berichtet uns
von der großen bild aktion erklären noch
einmal ganz kurz was es damit auf sich
hat und vor allen dingen wie man sich
auf der zielgeraden noch bewerben kann
ja kein patricia wir kennen das alles in
der silvesternacht sagen wir euch müsste
mich gesünder ernähren und so und dann
zack schon am nächsten tag hauptmann
sich irgendwas rhein und der vorsatz
schon wieder passé und da wollen wir
natürlich an setzen wir wollen dafür
sorgen dass die liebe zuschauer
tatsächlich wirklich die vorsätze
durchhalten und das macht natürlich mit
professioneller unterstützung das
prozedere ist relativ einfach heute ist
noch der letzte tag sich zu bewerben
welchen vorsatz haben sie welchen
vorsatz sollen wir helfen mit umzusetzen
und wir werden dann dafür sorgen sofern
sie ausgewählt werden welchen
professionellen coach oder experten wir
ihnen dann an die seite stellen das
heißt wir begleiten sie natürlich über
die zeit setzen auch ziele fest und wenn
diese ziele erreicht werden die werden
mit zwischen dem coach und uns und ihnen
definiert dann gibt's 1000 euro also das
ist der big boss der dann am ende auch
noch belohnt wird in sachen vorsetzen
wie genau kann man sich bewerben wo geht
das jeweils das ist relativ einfach
entweder per e-mail schicken sie ein
foto an an 1414 bild.de oder natürlich
wir freuen uns auch über video
einsendung die schicken sie dann am
besten über whatsapp am 01 71 9 59 22 11
wir sichten das dann und nehmen dann mit
ihnen kontakt auf sie sehen sie noch
einmal eingeblendet die etwas längliche
whatsapp nummer also das ist eine
möglichkeit uns ihr video ihre guten
vorsatz zu kommen zu lassen und das hat
claudia bokel genauso gemacht
hallo liebes team mit claudia bokel ich
bin 36 jahre alt verheiratet vater von
zwei sie sind jungs im alter von sechs
und seinen wagen und wir kommen aus
grafenau aus dem schönen bayerischen
beitrages unsere küche klein aber fein
unser problem ist wir haben viel zu
viele sachen ja und er gibt zu wenig
platz räumen zwar immer schön aus aber
wir haben einfach bei uns hier kein
system so hier sind in unserem fordert
kämmerchen gleiche problem viel zu viele
sachen und kein system im frühjahr wird
es immer alles aufgeräumt und nach
kürzester zeit schaut einfach auch hier
wieder aus wie in einer rumpelkammer ich
würde mal einfach hier auch einfach
merck system gelagert um wünschen ja das
kenne ich also so siehts bei mir ein
einschränken auch genau so aussieht auch
keine ahnung da lerne ich auch was dazu
wie man damals system reinbringen kann
aber erstmal wollen wir von frau wissen
welche ziele sie sich denn gesetzt hat
was sie schaffen möchte sie es uns jetzt
zugeschaltet sie gewerbeschein teil
schön dass sie bei uns sind ihrer
wohnung gesehen was genau haben sie vor
portugal können sie uns schon hören
ich glaube sie kann uns fern von wo
können sie uns einig wir haben sie
leider noch nicht werden gerade einen
blick in ihre wohnung werfen können was
genau haben sie vor welche ziele an sich
das gesetz was sie sich wünschen
hallo ja jetzt blöd dass ich immer alles
ordentlich ist außerdem zu den
versteckten türen und schränken sie
haben sie an billie jean und ist im boot
sitzt ja eigentlich immer wieder
aufgeschoben weil man kann ihr relativ
schnell einfach die tür wieder zu machen
und niemand gedacht mit beach versuch
und ist einfacher umzusetzen wald mir
einfach ja die restliche zeit ist
einfach viel mehr wird unsere familie
verbringen möchten die schöne zeit und
solvenz wieder warten ist einfach was
oder die unternehmen wollen und nicht
immer auch werben ich war total erstaunt
weil sie haben es gerade schon gesagt
dass sie total aufgeräumt eigentlich aus
so war auch mein erster eindruck von
ihrer wohnung was sie da gerade auf
ihrem handy video gesehen habe und dann
haben sie die schublade aufgemacht und
dachte jetzt weiß ich was sie herr jetzt
weiß ich was sie meinen warum schmeißen
sie nicht einfach was weg
jetzt brauchen alles noch
ok
das ist unser ja unser abstellkammer im
keller man wenn man in sachen die kann
man auch bereit man hatte ja wie lange
ich gebraucht aber vielleicht brauchen
sie hier in den nächsten fünf jahren um
im kleiderschrank es ist das gleiche ich
habe schon so was sucht man auszumisten
und dann steht man vor der tat blog
dabic mal die hose in die menschen zwei
jahren den knopf nicht mehr zu bekommt
ja der vorsatz ist ein bisschen abnehmen
und bis zum sommer passt man schon rein
organisch ändert ist die hose immer noch
im schrank und ja das problem kennen
viele
also wir holen jetzt mal einen profi
dazu und zumindest wären sicher beworben
jetzt schon mal eine ganz kleine er
vorab geschmack hilfestellung zu geben
uns zugeschaltet ist frau schicke die
kennt sich aus in chaos schränken
überhaupt wie man ordnung schaffen
könnte welche systeme man anwenden kann
wenn es einem so geht wie mir und frau
brutal wenn wir nicht mehr wissen wohin
mit dem ganzen grafl dem ganzen zeug in
den küchenschränken oder im keller
stellen dass sie bei uns sind wie geht
man dieses problemen an
ja hallo guten morgen erstmal die bilder
sind natürlich für mich ja immer das
gleiche kein problem für mich ist es
kein problem für die kunden schon wie
geht man es an also ich finde ganz
wichtig ist es sich wirklich mal
zusammen zu setzen und darüber zu
sprechen sich mal gedanken zu machen
nicht immer nur die tür gold sieht ja
alles so fürchterlich aus und das
schaffe ich nie tür zu und weg nein das
ist der falsche anfang der anfang ist
positiv denken was möchte ich ziele
setzen wie wie soll es aussehen ja und
wenn man sich ernsthaft darüber gedanken
macht ich glaube dann kann man auch
super gut anfangen und man freut sich
sogar drauf aber das funktioniert
wirklich mit ihrem mann mit ihren
kindern wie auch immer mit partnern
es wirklich machen sie eine kleine
versammlung darauf setzen sich zusammen
an tisch und besprechen sie die sache
und sand reden ihren gefühlen das ist in
weh tut das ist dass sie nicht mehr das
ist sie belastet einfach gibt es eine
frau brutal indem man anfangen müsste
eine horror schublade oder ein horror
schrank können sie uns gerne auch noch
mal zeigen
tatsächlich ist unser keller und
eigentlich die werkstatt und meint man
das große problem die werkstatt aber
tatsächlich ist so dass ihr eigentlich
vor zwei jahren eingezogen sind und da
steht nur eine arbeits tisch aber es ist
überhaupt wie die nägel und schrauben
alles in einem beschrankten obmann
passiert wird nichts und da bin ich mir
schon wünschen mal dass wir einfach ein
system als ordnung mit system wir haben
ein großer wunsch mein charakter
antreten unser abschnitte mit dem im
keller zeigen ein paar jetzt hat schon
jeder sein aber ist das alles digital
tag den würfel also ich wünsche mir mal
ein system das noch sagt auch
längerfristig dass er das egal zu sein
da kommt nur garten
[Musik]
frau stellte ein system wenn man also
das gespräch geführt hat den mann
überzeugt hat dass es nicht 1000
schrauben braucht sondern vielleicht nur
eine packung die kinder überzeugt hat
dass die spielzeuge von vor fünf jahren
vielleicht weitergegeben werden können
wie geht es dann weiter was kann man
dann machen um ein system zu schaffen
das auch langfristig ist an die an dass
ich dann auch alle halten ok also das
alte a und o ist einfach aussortieren
punkt da kommt keiner dran vorbei so wie
ich diese rolle wie ihm gesehen hat das
erlebe ich
nicht täglich aber fast täglich ist für
mich ganz klar der alltag das mein job
das kann ich gott sei dank
wenn ich diese bilder sehe denn dann
heißt es wie geht man am besten dran ich
würde immer empfehlen nehmen sie sich
eine schublade vor ein regal räumen sie
alles raus und dann ganz wichtig nehmen
sie die teile in die hand jedes einzelne
teile zum beispiel jetzt hier in der
küche jedes einzelne teil
und dann werden sie merken benutze ich
das einfach tut sich das gut an
welche bratpfanne benutze ich dann
wirklich oder die konserven in manche
sind abgelaufen manche ist man gar nicht
mehr nur weil man sie irgendwann mal
gekauft hat heißt noch lange nicht dass
man die auch aufbewahren muss und
vergessen sie nicht das geld ist sowieso
weg es ist ausgegeben es ist weg es
kommt nie wieder es ist vorbei aber sie
wollen klar horn sie wollen dass sie
sich wieder wohl fühlen dass alles
seinen platz hat und das geschieht nur
wenn man die dinge auch wieder zurück
liegt da muss da wo sie hingehören
das ist die ganze familie gefragt glaube
ich war das kenne ich auch die dinge da
hin zurück legen wo sie in einer frau
becker ich glaube da sitzen wir in einem
boot es geht meistens in einer familie
nur ein bis zwei grade mit mehreren
kindern personen die die dinge das
zurücklegen wo sie hingehören hier
scheint mir jemand hat sich leben allein
eine urania dieses problems zu sein weil
ich das aus der ferne so beurteilt das
schöne grüße
das ist ja schon mal anfang meine sorge
ist ein bisschen vielleicht ganz kurze
frage noch dass am ende jemand
unzufrieden ist bei ihnen zuhause frau
becker wenn plötzlich totale ordnung her
man scheint sich ja auch irgendwie da
eingerichtet zu haben so verhüllen es
könnte das zum problem werden könnte
tatsächlich das problem hat war meine
manchmal etwas aufgeräumt erstens selber
gemacht dann kann er doch mal stehen und
sie das nicht so bleibt das problem aber
ich denke wenn die werkstatt wirklich
selber anpackt weise auch nur was in tut
und daher bin ich wahrscheinlich suchen
aber das würden auf alle den kauf nehmen
vielen dank dass sie sich beworben haben
bei unserer aktion das ist schon mal ein
anfang die ersten tipps gab es von
unserer expertin sie bewerben sich bei
unserer großen bild aktion gute vorsätze
und dann dran bleiben über das ganze
jahr wir hoffen irgendwann in ihre
aufgerufen schubladen schauen zu dürfen
vielen dank
das ist tatsächlich noch ärgerlicher zu
hause wenn die sachen plötzlich woanders
liegen wenn davor hat man dieses mal
wieder so ist derzeit wohl nur das uns
nicht selber aufgeräumt hast sonst
würdest du sehr wissen woher das ist
wirklich ein kluger rat seine kollegin
patricia platziert kann den spar volks
von gm ganz wichtig heute noch bewerben
heute ist der längere bahnhof die die
heute um mitternacht genau also noch
einmal die e mailadresse 1414 bild.de
bewerben sie sich oder auch per whatsapp
geht's am 01 71 9 592 2 1 1 und dann
sehen wir das unternehmen wird mit ihm
kontakt an auf und begleiten sie dann
durch die vorsätze für unseren vorsatz
muster hier bei bild und bild live danke
frank